as you can imagine when you fly people
from Australia America you're not going
to worry about 10-15 minutes of time so
what I'd like to do actually I'd like to
invite chip and Liam up as well to the
stage and take a seat fly aboard which
makes me feel official but it also has
some questions that we've received from
people around so what I want to do is I
want to ask some of these questions
because people are around the world have
been asking us to to put this - to the
speakers and if anyone has a question
here if they can raise their hand so the
mic can come round with the mic that
would be fantastic
okay one thing that came out if I may
we'll start here and then Michael come
with a mic one of the interesting things
we've talked a lot about Japanese
martial culture today and one of the
questions that were sent to us was in
relation to firstly an individual called
Hwang soo Jin it was a credibly rotund
Chinese martial artist who lived here in
Japan in the 60s I wonder if anyone can
let me let us know what Drake really
thought of both Wang and also of Chinese
martial arts in general film oh yeah
this thing's so on you by coincidence I
was also a student of Wang sensei and
John myself and two or three other guys
we trained together don don was testing
a lot of different martial arts he
highly highly respected Wong sensei and
Wong was about my height and big man but
he was like a ballerina light on his
feet
very interesting fellow Don liked him
and respected him and we trained with
him for a number of years until he went
on to other organizations and went back
to Taiwan anyhow he was very famous man
in those days and very very tough very
tough to the point where he would say he
would stand in one in a house at dawn
rented in subletted runes rule a room to
which was called the castle and we just
used that room for a period a living
room for period of time he would take
off his belt and say you can hit me
anywhere you won them onto my body
except not my face hit me any way you
want
and they would stand there and he took
his belt off because he didn't wanted to
hurt our hands on his buckle he would
stand there I did it you know I don't
think I use 100% you don't have strongly
I mean you could see me mostly right
yeah I thought those days I didn't want
to hurt the man but I did use about 90%
of my power it hurt me and hurt some I
don't want to mention anyone elses names
but some well-known Japanese were there
too
and they had to suffer the same problem
so he told me because I was a student he
knew I did judo and he said relic that's
a way how you do it let's do some judo
all right I'm ready I grabbed him
and it was like grabbing that pillar
they didn't move and I tried to move
when he just stood there and he said how
long you been doing judo
however I've been doing a doodle for 20
years maybe 15 20 years and that's all
you can do but there he didn't speak
English but I spoke I was studying
Chinese so my Chinese is really messed
up but I could speak anyhow that can I
also hand that one too - leme lim you
are a practitioner and a teacher now of
Chen style Tai Chi in Melbourne maybe if
you have anything to add on on Drago's
thoughts around Chinese martial arts I
remember a long shift in being mentioned
it was when we were in Penang so early
August 1979 and we'd just gone to watch
practice of Phoenix officer Liang's dojo
and I talked very highly of Hong Shi Jin
and they both disgusting vulnerability
is to beat let anyone take a free punch
any nothing - I think it's a smart
recipe for a happy life don't let anyone
get a punch on you we had a question in
the audience sir mmm-hmm oh it doesn't
seem that we ever it it doesn't seem
that we ever hear much about any of the
difficulties or resistance that draggers
and say might have faced as a foreigner
who was here to Train and I wonder if he
ever shared any of that with any of you
and if so Holly dealt with it I mean
it's hard to imagine it went smoothly
for him all the time I'm curious about
what that was like for him and how he
might have dealt with those situations
thank you okay the answer that question
you're right there there are many times
when us foreigners all of us in those
days really got the wrong end of the
stick I mean they did it through a
tangle on what we weren't very happy but
really
I'm sure Dunn had problems too he was a
kind of a guy who took it he took it
from teacher he just took it like a man
and that's life he never complained
about it I never saw him come every once
in a while he'd say that guy over there
I'm sorry I didn't mean the point of you
guy next to your point that guy over
there was some Baba bad words I can't
say but there was gone it was boom was
gone he didn't have the problems that us
young guys had he went there a mature
adult a very sharp very confident and I
believe that the military made him the
man he was in that from that point of
view the war and being a military
officer and a Marine officer they were
highly respected and he fit he could
have played in any movie oh let me
mention on this one I've done because if
if also there are two movies that he
that I they're very very well known
movies that he was in he was a stand-in
for a seaman on the black ships movie
what was the called didn't know back in
the fifties sixties I think him out oh
darn it I have the name somewhere but
anyhow he dole of one of the would he
call these things masts into the water
no oh you're not well then you sharp guy
I'm a city boy I don't know those things
the second movie he was in he he was a
teacher for Sean Connery in The Only
Live Twice and I I gave I gave Don's son
a stack of pictures of them about an
inch high I just had I
had to give him things that he that to
let him know what is his father did
thank you
I'm gonna move on if you have a question
please raise your hand we'll get to next
this one I'm gonna ask each of you for a
response on because I I think a lot of
people have written in the said okay we
know drag it was almost like a polymath
of the martial arts he did a lot and
each of you in your own ways in your own
time have studied different martial arts
how did he deal with the separation with
the separation with the separation of
the different traditions chip can ask
you answer that one first you have to
remember my perspective comes from a
slightly different he looked at
principles it the martial art wasn't
about the techniques of the martial arts
it's about what the principles that
drove that martial art and as I said in
topology we we looked at the
commonalities and the distinctions he
was very good at picking out the
principles that drove any particular
system so rather than just trying to
mimic movement he caught on to the
principle very quickly and adapted in
that manner it's kind of a bass ackwards
approach that I would take if I was
gonna watch a kung fu system I'd try to
mimic immediately how do you put your
feet where do you put your knees how he
put your hips how to move your hands his
approach was to see the essence of the
system and I I can't really describe
that to you because I still haven't
figured it out but he was remarkable in
that capability film until chip came up
with a phrase one mind any weapon which
I think to a certain extent our stance
was the question occasionally he would
use me to demonstrate in a very
practical sense occasionally I
demonstrate it with him but I don't I
don't know what he did on me he's 70
we're not when I attacked I would get my
foot swept at the same time
so we get my throat damaged so play
around maybe you can come up with what
he was doing but I don't know you know
very good question I thought about that
in fact I had never heard that word
before polymath
but means do many things yeah okay
anyhow I've thought about that and being
a teacher myself I I've gone through a
lot of experiences in learning martial
arts and teaching it and most of my
beginners don't understand their body
and I have to almost teach them how to
walk and hold us what you walk and chew
gum at the same time or walk and hold
the weapon and to make movements really
a lot of people I like that and we could
that we go out I'm sure I was the same
don don knew his body well and I don't
think he had any problem learning
differences and used it I don't know
whether I followed you completely on
that chip but I tend to agree with what
you said use the word principle I would
say he understood to be honest with
physics how the body is balanced and how
if you lean forward at a certain point
you're gonna fall he know how to stand
straight up not not rigid straight but
he knew how his body worked completely
your your few feet support your legs
your legs support your hips your hips
support your shoulders there's a certain
alignment and he knew he knew him in
fact I think he played around a lot in
March was big it was quite easy for him
that's my answer
do we have any more questions a
gentleman at the front sorry there
please
I just like to ask a question about
Don's Japanese ability we have although
we all talk in English here but
can you speak to about you know how he
interacted with his teachers and
Japanese and how did he learn Japanese
language I've been talking what you want
has won the class or longer the answer I
can answer clearly ok good ok
I just pick Japanese I have a lot of
mistakes in my Japanese but I speak
Japanese I had to interpret for Don
however having said that Don knew enough
Japanese to keep himself out of trouble
he was very polite
and he got through things and and the
people still respected him Don had this
charisma about him where he could be he
could he could mess up and do some
foolish things and he did quite often
ask me to go along with him when go here
and there but he was headed here the
pride being the teacher the senior he
would never admit those things to me but
every once in a while I had to watch him
and I knew he had a problem I would give
him the key words of its yes not know
and he would follow it basically so he
wasn't fluent but he what he spoke
enough Japanese to get along ok
thank you I have a question
maybe each of you can have a crack at
this but our last chip to start if
Drager lived two pills H if we had
another 10 20 years what do you think
would have been the next steps for him
in terms of study and in terms of the
evolution of collagen collagen first of
all I know frankly he would have been a
cranky old man all right
I knew him from about the age of 55
until he passed away and I saw a change
in him in that time he became I think he
was aware possibly somehow of the
shortness of his potential lifespan and
he became less and less patient towards
the end he was in a hurry to get the
development done he wanted frankly he
wanted us to work faster and he put a
lot of pressure particularly on Phil but
all of us were feeling that and we we
weren't seeing things quick enough for
him and it if he had lived that extra
time and he knew he had that time it
would have been a lot easier on us in
that short term on the first on the
subject of his Japanese how good was it
well I think all three men speak much
better than at that stage anyway and I
wouldn't even compact dare to compare
myself with Alex I think he's really
very good I agree with chip I think he
would have developed into a very cranky
old man I have a bit of a different take
Don put a very strong effort on topology
and I was part of the team
in fact myself and another Chile myself
another person invested money and bought
10 acres of land on the island of of on
the big island in Hawaii 10 acres
I gave him one acre with four we were
going to build the I HRC International
hapa logical Research Center there in
those days we didn't have these things
so the most appropriate thing for us
would to get us a location somewhere
between Japan and America and there you
had Hawaii so we bought 10 acres and
like I said gave him one acre in the
corner and we'd planned to build a home
for him on there and he went and passed
away so if he had been alive we'd all be
in Hawaii right now I can live with that
I gotta take two more questions a
gentleman and raise his hand there I'm
gonna put over the mic sir I know I've
been asking a lot of questions tonight
and thank you for your patience I
thought a lot of the presentations that
people mentioned that Don was very
concerned with the preservation of the
traditional Japanese called you martial
arts I've also seen a lot of discussion
about what what exactly that means so a
bull but maybe at some time refers to
the question but what are your thoughts
about how about how he would feel about
the teaching and and and and the spread
so for example Jim you talked a lot
about applying some of these
psychological principles of that are
derived from behavioral science or from
the field of psychology that and this is
not the way that they teach in in in
these traditional code you systems
what would introducing things like that
be be appropriate or is the very
traditional teaching method still very
important for that for that transmission
of Cody we're gonna go across the
speakers again so maybe if I start with
you again Chet
maybe it depends on the system it
depends on the sensei of that system one
of the things I first learned from
Gregor remember I'm I was a karate guy
who's coming in from the average karate
dojo at that time we might have 10 15
people training at a time
what Drager the first thing I noted with
Gregor he was teaching Shindo mu so did
Joe in Honolulu at the time and I used
to come by dutifully and watch and after
two weeks of I'd read my black belt
magazine I knew how to approach this
properly right and I had shown proper
patience and you know respect and I had
been helping him with his hapa logical
work he I had day times free so I drove
him around so I thought okay I'm not
sure what they're doing with that stick
but I think I probably should do it and
I just assumed that when I asked him
he'd say yes so there's a little bit of
a shock when he said no and the reason
was he said in the type of training were
doing a teacher can't teach more than
four or five students at any one time
and this is something that I took very
much to heart if you've done Cody abou
Jitsu and you've done gendai Budo and
again die Bhutto you can have 20 pairs
of people working at a time and encoding
EBU Jitsu you rarely ever see anything
like that if you read about traditional
make ups of classes of Kodi boodle the
classes or courses are very very small
number of people there'll be one who Chi
Chi and two or three she'd actually
working at a time so I think there's a
reason for this and it's the same thing
when I started working with the military
I was doing courses for the military and
the Marine Corps wants to send 15 people
and can't do it if you're dealing with
something where you're threatened
punch a steel blade into somebody I
can't set up six pairs of Marines and
not expect some damage in the process so
what I found was that principle of
keeping it small work very effectively I
think that's the same thing if we were
to try to extend the life of the co2
yubu jutsu slash Bhutto today it has to
be done not on a mass basis not on an
institutional basis but it has to be
done case-by-case teacher by teacher and
view by do and I really don't know how
exactly how a group organization could
do that
so one of the reasons I'm here is I'm
hoping there'll be some interest
generated in this crowd and the people
we talked to last night in - how would
you do that from within whatever group
you work with how can you stimulate it
I'm involved in - Cordia total humble
could've naginata Jitsu and Tatsumi do
if they're more than six people at a
training session so there would be a
very big class on the question of the
survival or the call you
I know drag it was very concerned I
think it's not only it's not only a
question whether they survive but in
what form do they survive on the first
part of the question
I noticed recently someone had made a
list of Cordia actually in my country
Australia I went back and counted how
many Koryo are represented nowadays in
Australia they're 20 which is quite a
lot so in that way they can say the
survival is assured
but we can't say are they surviving in
the right form I think it's the trickier
question I'm not too sure not to answer
your question because it's so long since
I heard it however I may be of course a
bit excuse me if I am but Don wasn't
satisfied with many aspects of the
installed in Japan there's no
standardization in fact I've come to the
in the states I talk about this I've
talked about a number of times there is
not much pedagogy in Japan I think that
Japan provides technical expertise but
they don't know how to teach it the guys
who are teaching now are not so good and
he was kind of fed up with that in fact
that was one reason why he left
Khoda Khan and he had it when he was
converting from modern into call you
that he met he started mixing with
Kendall people and he told me very
clearly
Kendall people are sharp people they are
intelligent they're even though it's
quasi sport he put them up to hope I'm
not offending any judo people I'm a next
judo guy but he put the kindle people
intelligence up here compared to dude oh
man dude oh man he he got to the point
where he said he's worked with jocks
just guys who were doing it for sport
purposes competition and rank but if you
heard these two fellows talk about
hopple ology and what's what's behind
that you can see where his mind was
going dawn was really seeking more
information there is more available to
you guys if you're really serious if
you're really serious follow that route
of hopple ology you'll learn quite a bit
about it that's why thank you
I'm gonna ask how it's better to come up
here because he's waiting in the wings
to get up there if you don't mind
you notice he's got the black seed of
the family sorry listen ladies and
gentlemen we put this event together not
just to say there was a guy called Andre
ger he was an exciting guy and he did
all this good stuff we put this together
because if we don't stand on his
shoulders and move forward then we have
lost a huge opportunity so I'd like
everyone just understand that really
this event I hope will be held again
that this is the start of something I
hope it's too Phil's comments is a start
a renewal interest in hop ology but it
really does have the onus on us to do
that so please there are lots of
questions we didn't get answered here
people are still in me around here we
are going to be having some drinks and
dinner a little bit later
at which point I'm sure there's
questions I know dr. Bennett has some
questions he would like to ask we didn't
get to answer everything but hey that's
the good thing because in this game it's
all about moving from one point to the
next
asking questions learning and seeing how
far you can go and whether you're in a
court or a collegiate said again they
put up or a classical good up it's all
the same game I believe I put them up
there on stage and I put Alex there
because he really deserves to be there
for the effort the city put in but I'd
like you to join me in giving these four
gentlemen who's given an enormous amount
of time and flown a long way to be here
a very big round of applause thank you
now what as I said at the start what I'd
like to do is to take a picture I've put
them there in that position for a
particular reason because I'd like
everyone to gather round if you are
willing to be part of this picture then
please join us at the front so we can
take a picture of this event we're
delighted by the turnout I counted 65
people that's a good number
[Music]